welcome back Johnny and Youssef from
propane Fitness are here again today we
are going to discuss how to survive the
University how many degrees if we got
between us one and a you try to come one
and you're now a Bachelor of Medicine oh
yeah true I'm a is it a health science
diploma that you get after halfway
through and then so one one point my the
only one that knows okay you've got
you've got kinda - I've got two so
there's five degrees between us and I
cumulative amount if like what have you
got - so we've been at uni for like what
12 years between us sighing like that
yeah their time brings every possible
mistake that you can make at University
been waste man-- been super productive
and everything in between
I Reese after year at uni did you yeah
what for I would have never guessed that
so well it's part of what I want to talk
about fantastic when it just basically
came out of first year hard with
momentum within the same year wits with
same momentum stiffy
and then about a third of the way
through thought well so we've got a lot
to get through today um for those of you
who don't know what I do I'm a club
promoter now for the last 12 years or so
in one form or another I have had to
look after freshers they are usually
than when you make us first in terms of
guest Lister's so what that means is
that every year I get one year older but
the age of the people who work for me
and the situations that they encounter
pretty much stay the same it's just
faces and names that change the diverges
yet clear more old those people also do
get older is what Chris is saying is
that he's working with
for people if they're not fruit hasn't
hired action Chris is okay that's what
I'm saying though they are not frozen in
time I see a snapshot of them while I
continue to age and then this there's a
picture of them all that's in the Attic
of a dusty house and if they look at the
picture of themselves then they catch up
all of the years that have gone by and
then yeah and that's it so yeah I
thought one of the things that we all
know pretty well is how the [ __ ] up at
university and what hung common man to
prosper and well the thing is while I
was at university I really did I
prospered outside of uni but I was
categorically shite at university the
fact that I've got a 2-1 and then a
merited a master's is really it's a it's
a miracle so I think that means actually
the even mastered University honestly
mmm because it was kind of seamless well
like you're there for experience and
your degree is part of that experience
but if you just get a degree what a
waste of time
yeah for an expensive waste of time good
point so what do we want to start with
surviving freshers week is probably a
pretty good place to start
can you remember your first freshers
week yeah what happened did you do
anything funny just I just know a total
total overwhelm yeah experience all of
our well oh my mind although well
where's the overwhelm it cannot see it
so I think don't don't
I literally just hands behind your back
kamikaze headband on and just dope hope
don't do that no you need to go for the
alcohol just this with everything yeah I
think there are lots of things to
consume consume all of them in as much
as you possibly can just a week isn't it
so yeah just go dive right in how how
your fresh is because when you did your
first freshers week you would have still
been Muslim ik yes if I gots an
interesting point actually so I for
anyone who doesn't know I've done two
degrees one in maths and business 2008
to 2012 another one in 2013-14
up until now during which time I had a
crisis of faith
and I mean I've known a sausage because
something well another
it's a very slippery sausage and went
down the wrong the slope of care first
so first pressures weak pretty sensible
second freshers week you're five six
years older and you might Armand I'm too
old for this like even though 23:24 is
not really like super old but it you
realize the differential between having
to do that with a bunch of eighteen year
olds and you can you can smell the like
pulsating insecurity and this is a surge
of seeking approval because you've taken
someone who is in the stage of their
life along with a lot of alcohol new
people new environment and it just
creates this cocktail of desperation to
very of all fool like a Velcro level
grasping for some sense of assurance
soaked game and centering so there's
only why people like hook on to you like
the people in the corridor or like the
first person they meet they just become
instant best mates with and if he's just
only hung around with the people in your
corridor or whatever then you get this
misplaced sense of loyalty because you
would rise alright as I said this on the
social social chain podcast if you don't
play a sport and don't have a really
tight hobby that is going to immediately
give you some sense of first identity
and then second community with people at
uni what are you bonding with other
people over the people in your course
apart from the fact that they've also
chosen to do your course have in no way
been discriminated to your interests or
your mindset this is so it's my first
tip for surviving University surprise
surprise work for an events company
[ __ ] affiliate scheme no here's the
reason here's my justification for why I
think you should work for an events
company first off it gives you support
structure of people that are older than
you that understand the city they can
tell you as good to go for food where
you should go on a night out you'll get
to know a bunch of P if you're into
partying and if you like to go out and
drink you immediately going to get a
family Oh
200 to 400 other people all of whom have
got similar interests there at the same
University you've got a manager who'll
look after you the whole time
you get free entry to nightclubs you get
discounted drinks you get the family
that you need at University and it's a
fantastic support structure by is quite
a good point because otherwise like the
alternative is like if you don't expose
yourself to a wide range of people
straight away is that you end up like so
narrowing your slice of people that
you've experienced and withdrawing into
just you know this happens every single
time because I've seen so many freshers
come through as well where it's just
like they only hang around with the
first four people that they meet and
that's it and the first of all people
may not be may not be good for anything
that overlaps with them apart from the
only thing they have in common is that
they both were equally desperate to hang
on to someone near and then they end up
living with them for the following five
years and so widening the net of the
people that you can reach is a good idea
so things that I think going into
freshers whilst let's go through it yeah
bye yo so going into freshers I think
it's such a cliche and everybody says it
but like your grades do not matter if
you get 40% that is all that matters and
I even like everyone is like oh well you
know I know that you only need 40% but
like I sure know for me at university
there is quite a long period of time
probably six months to 12 months where
you just need to completely let loose
it's the first time you've been away
from home from your parents you've got
absolute liberation from all of the
previous confines you used to have and I
think if you don't take advantage of it
in your first year the fear is that that
then surface is in second or third year
when it does matter so bend yourself
I would advise as much damage as
possible to yourself in the first year I
can incite what you're saying throw
yourself in to the first year what do
you mean because you said that you you
went you kind of spread out the deck
advisor no I just didn't stop I see very
different about me so I can really
clearly remember
so one of the first times I met Dan the
broadcast Gibson he just happened to be
weren't sent school but were not
friendly at school he happened to be in
the the flat next to me we're on the
same course and I remember both of us at
one point having this conversation that
we were like we missed the library
tutorial because we were there was
something happening alcohol related
which didn't go to anything I hadn't go
to anything for like the first six
months at all because this would have
been before
like smart card check-ins and stuff now
yeah so like there was a hope that the
library was actually quite complicated
and so I didn't get a book out that uni
until 30th your 30th knows it because it
didn't have to but I remember being
really stressed about at the time
thinking like I'm [ __ ] uni that's an
honest if I can't believe I'm already
[ __ ] uni like it's ten days in but
like nothing happened
you didn't in spoke out until the final
year exams and then I didn't get booked
out ever it was all news or never got a
book report or not even in my Master's
never got a book at one the only time I
did get is about I had to intimidate a
Chinese lady he was starting at the
photocopy wood and then I took the book
went home went bought a new gospel and
stomached a ten-pound and a fine because
I was so worried those examples day yeah
no yeah I think so yeah don't worry
about all that I don't worry about intro
lectures and library tutorials and
there's maybe bit now many days did you
have it for would've been cheaper to buy
the book so you couldn't buy the book
anyway so I think go dick and balls full
length and testicles on first year
because I think actually the worst thing
that can happen after uni is that you
regret how you spent your time there but
I don't think you're ever gonna look
back as long as it doesn't impinge on
your degree yeah you're never gonna look
back and think God I partied far too
much in first year for a lot of people
obviously we're coming at this from the
side of a group that either still at
university or have relative amounts of
freedom to do what they want because we
work for ourselves
yeah a lot of people are going to go
into a much more bureaucratic
organization and their final bastion of
freedom it's their time at uni yeah and
I can imagine that if I feel like this
for someone who doesn't have that the
same level of freedom once they get into
a proper working retail it must be it
must be even worse
well in my experience that but people
living for the weekend once thinking
well that's just what happens
it's a hangover yeah it's oddly a
hangover of not drinking enough and
party enough uni so first tip is go dick
and balls during your first year
remember that the 40% grade that you
need that's it once you've hit 41%
it doesn't matter after that yeah now I
think that's probably not the same with
you though is it it's it's not but I've
heard people but I've seen people mess
up by saying like ah I only need to pass
40% so I'm just gonna learn 40% of the
course yeah very various if anyone's
taken what I mean is get a 40% grade
there's a learn 40% of the course they
deserve to fail fine
so your your first tip comes from a
place of get an audio system don't have
any lingering sense of like ah didn't
quite squeeze the lemon there and I'm
just going to spend the rest of my life
trying to catch up in the weekends
you're partying I think it's not just
not even just that it's just that
especially when you first arrive at
University for me what you should be
trying to do is get as much of a broad
cross-section of experiences and
exposure to people as you can
remembering I know that you got
University eighteen and you think that
you understand how the world works but
I'm telling you as someone who's thirty
years old you don't even have the first
clue like I look at the boys that work
for us now the managers who I'm closest
with and then the girls as well who were
the guest list isn't stuff below them
and some of our status etc etc and
there's so much further ahead than I was
at their age like so much more mature I
think that exposure to the internet
means that people are able to grow up
and be exposed to different people more
quickly and yet there's still like
broadly like children like their
children who can legally drink drive and
play so exactly what David said as I was
leaving the house I was like David what
do you what's your survival tip for
University
like you're gonna be [ __ ] the whole time
but you're gonna think that you're
awesome mm-hmm there you go
right though he's definitely right so I
think be be aware of the fact that it's
a learning process in all areas of your
life and don't try and take I think
don't try and take anything too
seriously I certainly thought that I
wasn't prepared to mess up because I was
economic University there's all this
pressure on me I'm supposed to be this
adult who's living on his own he was
supposed to have his life so I don't
like 12 years later still not got my
life up do though still mess up all the
time so don't think that that's
something that you need to do there was
a there was a really clear moment for me
about three months in really sharing my
darkest moments here so I'm sat in the
corner of my room because there was
nowhere else to sit because there was
just mess all over the floor
and I was eating a cold pot noodle sat
perched in the corner eating his crock
pot noodle and I just looked in my room
and I thought I'm gonna do something
about me and I don't think like I
thought slowly did mm-hmm
but I just I really felt like I apart
from the gym I just let go everybody was
just like right I'm just gonna
absolutely I just felt like I was in a
playground hmm just go time and maybe
that's not the right way to go about it
but I definitely don't look back at that
and think that was stupid yeah I think a
good a good thing to do is potentially
try and join a sports team or a society
I wish that I had doubled down more on
the opportunity to play spirit reason
for that is like when you get to 25 or
30 like going I'm gonna start rowing
like no you're not no you're not as fast
as you're not going to start rowing but
that you need this is a time to try new
things so good like I remember thinking
Ultimate Frisbee was like weird and now
I think if you gave me the opportunity
to try all them a frisbee free okay
you're absolutely right will know that
one do all them a frisbee so I think try
as many different societies sports and
societies as you can
I'd like to segue onto you Yussef about
trying to get some low-hanging fruit for
studying tactics
so here this is one thing that I had
like you can't often completely write
off your entire first year and as it
being a waste but one of the things that
you should do is begin to grease the
groove of at least understanding how to
study effectively so yeah I've got it so
I split my notes up into this different
section so before we were going to study
just the final thing on freshers week
and this desperation for approval and
people latching onto each other is an
example that I saw of a guy second time
around with my freshers week
second-degree who was 18 he was called I
say his name but he was matching
insurance money thing but he was a
Muslim guy and he was drinking and I was
chatting to him about his Muslim family
I was like do you finally know that you
drink oh that's actually the first time
but how come you're drinking it was like
just you know especially you cannot have
two because this is the pressure or like
do you even like it was like no like we
don't just like completely compromise on
who you are for the sake of approval
don't you just like do this because you
think that's what you're supposed to do
I was like look I took it out and I was
like just be you don't don't try and
because this is the slippery slope this
is the time when if you make that one
compromise now that's it like there's
numerous ones that are gonna don't you
say yes points
even people are doing that Muslim or not
in loads of ways in feels like if you
like it yeah go ahead
yeah like but the fact that you are
saying you don't even like doing this
but well I did notice I did loads of
stuff that I thought that I thought I
liked at the time like I was going out
all the time and I very quickly realized
that to me I was much more interested in
developing my business and like I want
to spend time developing my business but
because all of my flatmates weren't like
that I like you felt like a weirdo yeah
I loaded pizza then realized I like
dominos but they don't like I remember
you know the Peter thinking this is like
[Music]
studying studying so we're studying the
the best way to go about this is not to
think
I don't need to go to lectures no one's
checking up on me here this is great I
pray I can just like to start working a
week before the exam just if you really
want a good degree like if you're there
to get a degree in to get a good grade I
treat it like a day job you're the one
that's the master of your own time then
and I guarantee if you treat it like
that there is no way you'll get anything
less than the first if you just treat it
as like a nine-to-five during the day
same way as when you eat with you when
you were doing a-levels you didn't you
couldn't go home during the day you just
turned up did the work came home maybe
did a bit of homework but you don't even
need to do that set yourself a really
hard rule of no Xbox during the day no
nonsense before 4:00 p.m.
doesn't even have to be a full nine till
five and once you've done that your
evenings are fully free there's no guilt
you rate the fun stuff tends to happen
in the evenings anyway and then you're a
free agent this infraction if this in
first year first year like it depends
how scared you are of failing like I
think as you said Chris like people are
often you get two types of people the
neurotic ones that are too afraid of
failing and ironically they're the ones
that need to pull back a bit and then
the ones who think I'll be fine
they're the ones that fail so you you
almost have to look at your own track
record and say have a bit of
self-awareness to say am i someone who
is legitimately at risk of failing or
I'm very difficult as a young age to
work out that sort of a thing now is
because Cambridge suicides at the height
the people who commit suicide of
Cambridge are the highest performance
because they're the ones that have the
most neurotic fear that they're going to
fail or they're not a terrifying
statistic I think I think what what I
would say is I had a very
well-established revision ritual which
was I'd identically learn everything on
a page so I'd write out my notes for the
exam I would summarize the entire module
write out notes for the exam and then
just learn it for beta so I could then I
wouldn't I could even remember when
looking on the page oh there's that top
left hand but okay so I'm learning about
so to do
counting okay what are the four prints
he has like a Cambrian age and then I
would have summary eight pages and I
would learn them verbatim like allow
myself to read until a bit read a new
bit close the page trying to remember it
if I could remember it go back learn
another bit and just compound it on top
that's what the guy in your learning
what concern but he does but he talks
about he doesn't talk about doing it as
verbatim because what the problem I came
across from doing that was that I had a
glass ceiling and box and sides on
everything I knew because if it was
normal you know done [ __ ] because
interpretive ly I had nothing but for
courses like business accounting like
there's no creativity required you don't
need to be create with your answer so I
think that strategy works extremely well
when there is a finite curriculum and
it's like if you learn that stuff in
these summary notes you've got an if
you're doing philosophy or classics then
you then you need to read like and those
those degrees are s why they say like
what are you reading you know it's like
a university it's like me you do you
have there's no way around that
but you end up with a lot more depth of
knowledge as a result and you can
interpret and so yeah the the guy the
main thing that Joey taught me from your
podcasts about learning was the guy
saying learning and memorization is
repeated recall and not repeated
exposure to the material and loads of
people they just like we read their
notes loads of times and highlight and
it's like then you just create the
familiarity fallacy familiarity paradox
where like you know if you know oh yeah
oh no that was fine fine close the point
city if you can tell me yeah and you're
like oh no so that's good that's good
for studying um I think relationships
I've I've wanted for studying hit me so
something that I wish I had done so I
feel like uni is the biggest example of
Parkinson's law for most people so it
depends on the type of degree D that
clay explained parking some slaw please
so you take as long to complete
something as you allocate to that tasks
if you say I've got it's the epitome of
you so I you come out school where
you're given day structures lessons
homework you're basically a a map
between starting point and end point is
built for you with the
the little check marks on the way you
dropped them to Yui and someone says
right here you are for three or four
years you have to get a degree at the
end of this you don't even need to turn
up so you don't even need to turn up
like if you don't end up with something
they will say to the odd like stiffs on
the res email that's it so what I did
certainly in certainly first and second
year was you wait until it's like three
weeks before the exam something like oh
my god there's all these lectures to go
through if I had done the 30 minutes of
work a day the entire time I was there
and kept on top of like lecture today
like what were the key points can I
understand can I explain them
forget about it love the rest of my life
how many people been to university
they're listening now or at university
now or even they've done a levels of
GCSEs left the revision until the night
before yeah that's me all over the
Parkinson's Law work expands to fill the
time given for it and that's the reason
why people do it beforehand I think it's
very telling of people's personality
types my business partner Darren very
very procedural likes to schedule things
in he would have finished it even I
don't think I ever saw him finish an
assignment
he did the same course with me later
than like the Thursday before the Monday
it was it and it would be me who would
be leaving one of our events at 3
o'clock on a Sunday morning for a 9:00
a.m. handed on a Monday morning
going back someone would have a party in
my flat downstairs and I'd be upstairs
like going downstairs to have cans of
Red Bull
so my Master's dissertation I'd done
4,000 of 12,000 words 36 hours before he
was due to be handed in and I stayed oh
he stayed up for a day and a half full
case of Red Bull and just wrote the
whole thing and I was so wired and
wrecked by the end of it that I didn't
trust myself to drive to town to bind it
so I walked to town from Jesmond to get
my dissertation bound because I wouldn't
trust myself to drive so trusting myself
to complete a 9,000 pound Master's
dissertation I'd be working on every
year but didn't trust myself to drive
two-handed I'm not sure if that's an
advert for doing that or I don't think
no it was just it was just and the fact
that I got through it as well to me my
kind of synopsis of uni overall was that
it was just get it done by any means but
now looking back
I think that that should have been an
identified to me that I didn't care
about the course so I did business
management then I did international
marketing and how they have done
philosophy of psychology I would have
been sufficiently stimulated by the
material that I did to actually want to
learn where it's very quickly it was a
transactional relationship between me
and university who are that that needs
to get out to dinner right I don't know
minimum effective dose and ongoing
stress before like say three months
before it was in okay fine so at least
you wouldn't you weren't bearing that
that load on your head of like are that
things in for three months time like
it's always weighing on you and I said
two things that came up for both of you
the thing about handing a dissertation
like ours before that is before the
deadline my flatmate
did that and ended up because it was
Universal time for dissertation hand in
at twelve o'clock on a certain day all
the printers and all the libraries were
jamming and massive bagging a person's
heart of paper and he was losing the
plus absolutely losing his mind innocent
there and made me think like you've had
a year to know about this yeah there's
nothing about that deadline that is
particularly much about you know you
know you could have very easily had all
this stress and stuff in week one or
week fifty to burn and so the
Parkinson's Law thing applies so much so
as a rule as a rule of thumb would you
say that it might be an idea for
everyone to just remove two days from
the day like at least like remove the
two or three days from the dead last
ever I'm gonna avoid printer problems
you're going to avoid file losses oh we
should do yeah how do you how do you
work in a manner that means that your
files never get lost
so the I mean I've had an assignment
that I've kind of really internalized
that lesson I had an assignment that I
had to hand in it's due for mid-october
I handled it in two weeks ago so that's
about mid-september so that's a month a
month early because I was like I just
don't want it on my head I mean the
deadline is irrelevant like it has to be
done by that point okay I'm not gonna
fit my life around the deadline I'm just
gonna do it when I have capacity and get
it done but we seem to think that the
deadline becomes like
the point of focus and then our life has
to then mold around it which is a
terrible way to work the the Parkinson's
more thing as well about doing 30
minutes a day for any degree is so
valuable but there are certain degrees
that the stack of work is not possible
to back load if you're doing certain so
medicine is one of them and I've
experienced two degrees I did maths and
business which I know is not like a
hardcore degree but the the first term
of the first year of medicine was harder
than the entire four years of my master
business degree in terms of like total
workload total cognitive load everything
like that Wow and so then what they say
about studying medicine is like eating
10 pancakes a day like it's fine to eat
10 pounds a day but if you miss a day
about 20 things to him very quickly
becomes an insurmountable amount of
funky yeah if you give him out what's
the the most my regular pancakes yes
they should give it to you you know I'm
305 kilos if you have about 200 I said
but talk to me okay so how how are
students going to avoid their work being
lost if it was me working in past me and
it would be Google Drive but now I just
saved everything on my computer it was
just all fine all the right line I had
the three backups of my dissertation
like physical cloud and so I just would
you would you advise anyone doing a
bachelor's for a higher to use Evernote
yes so how would you use it briefly so
you can use Evernote or hundredths and
notes it doesn't matter and I know you
probably like because I'm mr. paperless
but in some sergeant paper sergeant
paperless but left hand okay like I'm a
very anti paper but I recognize that
some people like paper and it does help
you in the data to learn better
so handwriting still does improve we
call so if you can do that fine but you
have to be systematic from the start and
you can't let any single thing get away
from you so what's this what's the
system so whether you have
separate files for separate modules the
chronologically ordered or whatever it
is but anytime you have any scrap bit of
paper any lecture slides whatever it is
don't just think I'll print it off later
or I'll sew it later like put it into
the filing system straight away because
if you don't you will end up with sub
piles and it would be like a bug in the
system that just compounds so you were
then four I'm gonna guess anyone who
doesn't understand how to use Evernote
you have notebooks and then within those
notebooks you have notes so no but I gr
is equal filing system but digitized it
is the onion to all he'll three layers
it's all held in the cloud so it's cloud
aren't local which is good it is three
let's say you have notebook stacks which
is like groups of notebooks so like a
box with all your files in yeah the
notebooks then have some notes in which
are each one is a little plastic folder
and then the notes you can search by
title or you can tag and so then you can
have two ways of categorizing the same
thing so you could have yo one module
one notebook under the year one stack
but also you could tag the certain notes
within there as cardiology and then any
time other things within the branch of
cardiology come up into if you're a
third year and you need to look at
something about cardiology it'll pull up
everything across all the years so I
think for me the main reason that I like
that that I like the idea of using
Evernote is how many times have you seen
someone post that I see all the time so
I've got a lot of students on my
Facebook X number of thousand words
through my piece of work computer
crashed and didn't save next Y Zed and
you go I mean yeah it is it's
vomit-inducing yeah and I've never had
that I don't think I ever had it happen
seriously maybe like 500 words as a as a
gap but the fact that I was doing it on
this weird incremental discrete sections
of saving of work on Microsoft Word
feels [ __ ] history girl like just
then use Google Docs with Google Drive
is free and Evernote if you upgrade for
what like five pounds a month it's
incredible I've not seen anyone like
whatever I recommend it in they're like
oh my god like how did I not
know about this before and we know that
it yeah whenever I seen you one sat in a
lecture with a Microsoft Word document
ever made you're so basic like it just
get ever know start using it now and if
this is the thing about greasing the
groove right if you start using Evernote
in your first year then you're in the
rhythm of it when it really matters when
ii yo' kicks in in third year this is
the thing about the ten pancakes or the
bug in the system that very very soon
it'll be a year later and your heart
you'll be like oh god i could collect on
my nose yeah and if they're just indexed
cuz you don't want to be spending you've
got a month to revive you don't be
spending half of that time just
collecting your notes and trying to pull
them off things and find where they are
and download them from the portal and
yeah you know that is it only becomes
insurmountable
if you don't just manage it in a way
that is but just establish a process
establish a like how much work am i
willing to do today what's my minimum
effective dose to keep on top of this so
it doesn't become a house fire I can't
get out and do it the people don't just
fitness as well yeah yeah what I'm gonna
say what the topic isn't it so moving on
a couple more tips on academic before we
what I what I think laughing right
incidentally is just how I don't think
the that where your advice is coming
from it's such a lie Eve that you did a
Russian memory quality motion Russian
memorization cause truth Hey tones or
something if but there's a lot yes foot
42 modules and it was like you you are
running a business while doing a medical
degree and managing boots it's so
interestingly that was something where
like you know when people say about you
and you realize how strong you you are
when you're capacity when it's fully
challenged and you have to get work to
that yeah and I'm realizing how much of
a serial waste mom I was in my first
degree the amount of time that I wasted
yeah whereas now like knowing all of the
stuff that we're discussing in this
podcast if I'd went to do my first
degree again they would have been an
absolutely just would've had you
cock-ups
a full-time job could have done whatever
stress frees you such a different person
by looking back like I the prospect of
even being more organized just didn't
trust me it didn't even it didn't even
factor into your lungs yeah it wasn't
because you think that's an overwhelming
force I don't need that's our approach
just to just to pass my Yuri and it's
like well yeah that's that's true but
you are absolutely capable if you're
listening to this podcast you're smart
enough and you're capable enough to put
all of these systems in place from the
beginning and get away with an hour of
work a day or two hours of work a day
and smash it this this may sound like if
you're in second or third year that it's
a lost cause all that was saying is that
greasing the groove early is good but
greasing the groove and having a system
at all is infinitely better than having
not so if you're listening to this and
you're starting third year or maybe
you've come back and decided to listen
to this and it's the beginning of
January or something like that like are
you doing an MBA whatever it is look at
the sort of system that we're talking
about which would be Evernote get
yourself a routine during the day have a
wake up time do you go to most days if
you're if you're hungover okay do the
same thing again but have a routine for
when you're hungover don't allow
yourself to sleep in after midday if
you're hungover they have a contingency
plan even for a hangover yeah exactly
you've got numbers of routines rather
than one single routine Ryan holiday
recently did a very good Evernote post
about it where he says he don't need to
be militant about your routine you just
need to be militant about your routines
okay the thing you have a finite number
of consistent situations that you that
you come up against all you need to do
is when it happens once if it's new
model it it'll never happen again him
you're not used to it once yeah that's a
good chart so on that note never there
any circumstances work with people don't
go to the library with mates and do this
kind of [ __ ] yeah those are people
well it's been spending 16 hours in the
library and they work a 15% capacity and
you're like well you may as well have
done one hour they're just not valuing
that time properly as absolutely Brian
Brian from optimize not me does this
looking thing which is work done equals
time times intensity yeah you know right
okay so I can do 10 hours at 30
I can do three hours a hundred percent
which you want to do and the three hours
at 100% are going to bury themselves in
your mind more deeply as well and you're
gonna have a greater sense of
satisfaction at the end of the day once
you complain even relaxing you know
constantly elevated sense of stress
because my whole first degree was that
it was sick I did a lot more work than I
needed to and it was a lot well a lot
more time working than I needed to
there we go actually on that on that
point I think try and create your room
at university whether it's in halls or
in a house or private residences or
whatever once you've completed it have
your room at university with a desk and
an area which is conducive for you to do
work by spend a little bit of money
avoid a couple of nights out and spend a
little bit of money on a nice seat or
get your mom and dad to buy you a nice
office seat and then you're like right
okay I now have no excuse for not doing
my work and I can do it in silence in my
room or I can listen to music but if
it's music it's my music yeah and if you
don't trust yourself to do that even
even if you had to say like I've got my
desk Wi-Fi I'm gonna unplug the router
I'm literally just gonna like but if you
can't trust yourself to do that then
only work in the library and never work
but work in a kiosk in the library sorry
on your own and locally rotate in it
yeah somewhere that's like the
anti-social we used to have a place
called the bunker which was like they
were phone signal in the ground or
something yeah it was like it was
literally underground like I think it
used to maybe used to be a bunker and
like hardly anyone was there it was 24
hours a day there were showers and it
was just this wasteland of a of a
computer room yep and it was just dead
silent Oh lovely that's what he's yeah
that's right
because also if you go somewhere that is
really unpleasant to be then you're like
right I've got this set of tasks to do
I'm gonna go to that place and because
it's unpleasant I'm gonna have an
inherent incentive to spend the minimum
time there so I'm just gonna spend
that's why I like the idea of having
even now like I've only recently given
mus got back to having a home office in
my room and I love it like it's just
somewhere else where I can do work and
it's not it's just a nice it's a change
of scenery it's silent that's because
now you're self-motivated to do I
suppose you said the area you made was
you doing
degree that didn't feel aligned with
what you were so I guess motivating
stuff to do it at home you be like man
this is so moving on relationships I
think would be quite incredible I just
have one more just final thought yep
just bit I'm just imagining what 18-year
old me would think yeah if I was listen
to this as you think what the [ __ ] well
exactly because you wanna have a good
time but I think trying to look at us
you're buying a very expensive either if
it's vocational qualification that
requires you to go and be a doctor or
architect or whatever or a very
expensive signal to employers which is
like I'm semi-organized it's extremely
expensive so you need to get that
outcome so how do you have the best time
while creating that outcome and having
that discipline actually creates the
best experience yeah so it's the
discipline equals freedom idea but
without when people think I'll just a
lot around like do what I did they say a
lot around and then crazy stressful
chunks of my uni life hmm actually just
chip away that you'll have the best time
of all the time get a good degree a
really good point the fact that doing a
little bit of work and consistently will
allow you to have more spare time you're
inversely it sounds like oh well you're
asking me to be constantly working no
I'm not I'm asking you to split your
work up into money after you should I
look anyway and if you're not going to
do the work then you need to leave
University so you're going to do that
volume of work so just do it in a
manageable way and you'll be that guy
they're always like how is he getting
well like you said how's he getting
those results while he's doing doing all
these other things and he's still
getting these results it's because of
the processing system cool so
relationships Johnny he said that you
had some comments on relationships at
university so I I broke up with my
girlfriend just before I went to
university okay because he were going to
university yeah because I have I
remember thinking like I can't possibly
go to university with a girlfriend which
is why I don't know but so when I got to
uni like a few people I was living with
hard at relationship they were still in
I remember thinking like what are you
doing it's like someone arrives like
having not enrolled on their course
but best decision I ever made I think
how long did the relationships of the
people who you lived with lust not long
after all it was like the battle of the
somme honestly it was just I remember
people getting shot live dry it seems
like you just watch people cheat on each
other and it was just oh yeah there was
a lot and especially the people who were
in the long-distance relationship so for
the long-term unlike yeah a week later
you see them just in an orgy with I
think it's what you saying Chris about
like you go to uni thinking I'm 18 man
like I know what's going on I know what
I want I know what my values are you
haven't got a clue
so like hampering that first year of
your life at university when you're
gonna meet probably the most
concentration of new people have all
these like weird intense experiences of
people even like make that's my patent
IV I'm doing my patent like a
lightweight experience that's a common
experience exactly like what I use eat
my bacon why sort of stuff like you just
need time to figure it out you don't
need to have it's crippling isn't
something else to manage it I think that
that's a really nice way to come at it
because it can quite easily lead to us
sounding like we're saying you should
just spray it around as much as possible
during your time at University which
isn't necessarily right I think what
we're saying is that you should expose
yourself to as many learning experiences
as you can and a relationship is nothing
short of a mitigating factor in that now
a lot of short relationships at
university I actually think it's quite
good to go the learning experience but
if you're going to look at anything you
would take some statistics and you would
then model what you're going to do off
the back of your statistics
I would love there to be a
representative sample of how many people
arrive at University with their
girlfriend or boyfriend that they had in
college and what the drop-off rate is
because mine lasted until did you arrive
at uni with a girlfriend and that that
was like my first main girlfriend as
well right so I was like a card like a
you know you've got this sense of
belonging you've got this kind of I'm
never had a girlfriend before or you
know
- I'm naturally oddly sentimental in any
case so that kind of all was a perfect
storm of me just not letting go and it
was just I ended up sacrificing so many
experiences a uni and that's not turning
down girls to sleep with all of
obviously that was part of it it was
just stuff like that that person is a
different stage of their life than you
are even if they're a different
University it's a different stage of
their life freaks it's a different place
and you end up am I gonna go to this
cricket social no I'm not my
girlfriend's off means man it's like so
my 21st birthday for instance was
another girlfriend who was spent with my
then girlfriend crying to me on the
phone because I decided to go out with
my mates instead of going to see her my
21st birthday so I didn't have a good
21st birthday at all regardless of
whether I was with her or still at
university and I'm just you managed to
remotely mess it up yeah really like
Renee's you know I think yeah like just
I think Lavigne to me and this dish
shouldn't be this shouldn't classes like
if you are in a relationship you should
get rid of it I think the the best model
for this is if you're in relationship
when you go to university and you're
confident that you want to stay in it
then do so but the second that you think
that it that you are unhappy in the
relationship then call it quits there
and then because not only are you
wasting your own life but you're wasting
the other person's life because they can
be happy with someone else as opposed to
being happy with someone who's unhappy
with them even just the headspace that
sorry I remember like you go to sort of
a there's loads of stuff that goes on in
freshers week parties and meeting new
people and also stuff people with
boyfriends and girlfriends were
definitely in like a less open frame of
mind going there's been new experiences
what if someone makes a move I can't do
anything I'm gonna have to have a talk a
conversation I'm gonna have to say well
where were you last night I went to this
after party and exactly like well no you
should go into the after pipe because
you've never been to one before exactly
yes
yeah the predominant theme I saw with
those with people who are in a
relationship was fear anxiety
trepidation just like they're just
desperately hanging on to you what they
know it's a from our home relationship
yeah and so they're just like then just
not it's like yeah it's dipping your toe
into the whole experience and being oh
it's okay because I've got a girlfriend
it's almost like a excuse or a shield
them as being you very much though I
think people use to a degree I've seen
some people use sports as that as well
so that they'll choose to not do
something social that take somehow of
their comfort so make no but rugby so
yeah because I've got this and it's like
well no hang on you talk I'm okay I'm on
the C team exactly no one even knows you
know it's I think as well falling into a
relationship during and freshers week or
the first few weeks of the like they say
the same as like the you know the first
people you mean you just latch on to be
exactly like there is going to be no
time in your life that you're going to
meet such a wide range of people like
just accept the sheer odds that are in
front of you that the likelihood of you
meeting the person you should be in a
relationship with being within the first
couple of days and also living it on
your floor in your Holst infinitesimal
it's probably pretty low yeah well
you're extremely fortunate yeah yeah
well I mean but that's what that's in
the back of everyone's minds right is
that what it's all no no this is this is
why it's right it's right because we're
so close and you're like no it's not
it's a [ __ ] nightmare because you're
so close I see all the time right like
these guys and girls come to University
and they've just tumble straight into a
relationship because it gives them a
sense of comfort it gives them this
sense of belonging someone's got their
back and it just turns toxic so very
very fast hmm again what I want to try
and get across isn't getting into
relationships at university isn't
necessarily a bad thing
the problem is clinging on to them once
they're already gone like you know you
know that it's gone and treat it if it
was easy come treat it is easy go and
that's one of my primary problems at uni
was a letting go of things like that
like sigh it was very very difficult
for me and so I didn't want to a sort of
grabby fear - just like quickly just pin
something down the sights familiar isn't
it it's young you searching for
familiarity in a time of your life where
everything's new and nothing stays the
same it's a lovely way to put it I think
as well another another thing is that
your sample size so 18 years old your
sample size if life experience is so low
like you've really at 18 only been close
to the person that you are right now for
probably about two years because two
years ago you were a completely
different person when you to new GCSE
yes I mean so if you if you've been with
it like that mental is [ __ ] crazy so
think about the fact that if you're in a
relationship for six months at the age
of eighteen so that large fraction of
your life it's a very it's a significant
proportion of the time you've been alive
[Music]
yeah and you go right okay so I need to
try and look upon this and that's the
problem with this perspective I think a
lot of what we're trying to get across
here is the fact that you need
perspective it's horrible because I had
such a lack of self-awareness combined
with a lack of experience and this so I
mean I'm so I'm so lucky that my
girlfriend broke up with me before I
went to uni cuz I and I was upset at the
time forgot about it within a week
because of he's starting that you know
uni and then I was like actually that
unconsciously poorly articulated feeling
of what you've described both of you
like the seeing people in a relationship
and just seeing something a bit held
back about them and a bit like unwilling
to dive in and the people who were in a
relationship
yeah they'd fallen at the first hurdle
because they're they've like they're in
cling mode already but then the people
that fall at the second hurdle are the
ones that then jump into a relationship
with the first person that they that
they sneak whether they meet in you've
had the worst of all scenarios because
you've had you've missed out on months
of experience you've had to navigate a
failed relationship remotely while at
uni potentially something romantic man
awful conversation brilliant a fifth day
route my 21st birthday
getting into another argument I was in
another argument as I was trying to
write like the first set of exam the
first serve assignments for my masters
I'm just looking at masters mmm
sure so masters I don't know it's there
whether you want could it
it sounds off compared to you the rest
of your accent but I don't know what I
say it's always one of those moments
it's like a it's like plaster or plaster
you know I say you write I sliced out
for everything else but masters I always
I don't know what like what's the name
of this app without thinking about it
GarageBand I'm not garage but GarageBand
we've been about that that's American
yeah
abdomen up dude what would you say would
you say masters I bet you what masters
yeah you would I'm hybrid I think God
anyway about plasterboard plasterboard
plus a blood bath plasterboard uh-huh
masters offices so I would say plaster
cluster but plaster plasterboard yeah
I'd say that's why the earth is on and
I'm just going to go plaster the wall
how do you like it would you like a
plaster you like a plastic glass do you
think do you I don't know you can't do
if you just like no gentleman anyway so
on the topic of on the topic of being
single at University
I haven't seen that's that's my point
okay my point is yeah for the love of
God we're a prophylactic whicker's the
easiest way to do it is by them at the
start of a year by a big box like a xxx
box of G Rex yeah stick with bronze keep
one in your wallet
that's all in it King of Thieves so have
a buffer level of them and keep one in
your wallet all time again for free so I
thought keeping it in your wallet can
cause a Parisian here if you suddenly
was I've been mourning but Padre okay
book just a moment rather haven't I
would rather have Ana braised condom
then no condom it's always an argument
to say better a to drop it in the UK you
should be giving you they put a tiny
little pin back in the edge stay for
this time they're crossing price and
then yeah the tears of efforts but the
receipt receipt receipt receipt
not only girl in the math class he gonna
be like so put them in the bedside table
next to your bed because it it's it's
the same as defrosting the chick in the
night before you don't be frost the
chick in the night before you can't food
crap in the morning if the condom isn't
near the bed it's an erection
there's the likelihood it is an erectile
and killer is I'm gonna touch I'm gonna
touch on something that I've wanted to
talk about for ages and I'm gonna
probably gonna bring up on another one
you Iraq tile dysfunction yeah Wow
so guys at university it is normal it is
absolutely normal for you to not be able
to get it up when you're pissed it's
absolutely normal to not be able to get
it up when it's in your head that you
can't get it up as well but for me at
uni I think it was maybe my third year
and I was absolutely blind drunk out of
my mind drunk couldn't get it up when I
went back with a girl and then that
started to become a self-referential
echo chamber that was like okay now I've
only had a couple of drinks
oh god that problem might happen again
then it does and then it gets to this
stage where you like oh [ __ ] maybe this
is gonna start happening when I'm sober
and sure enough actually does and you're
like right okay I need to break the
spell of this somehow and it's really
really difficult and I've I've got a
number of friends who have this has been
a cascade into a really really horrible
situation and all that it needed was
someone to say this which is it is
perfectly normal to not be able to get
it up when you're pissed and if you
laugh it off she'll laugh it off as well
and if you're a girl it doesn't matter
if it's never happen to you before it's
not about you it's about the amount of
alcohol that he's had to drink and if it
happens be gracious about it and just
say don't worry you're not the first
like because that is just gonna make him
go I thank God for that
yeah that makes me feel so much better
because at 19 20 years old thinking I've
got a reptile dysfunction crushing it's
[ __ ] terrifying did it happen to you
it Titus happened make up the time Joe
and heals through a little psyche it's
there it's the thought it's the
split-second of goddamn much anymore
because you've given people the safety
couch to just to stop with the safety
valve to stop that happening and if it
happens in the moment you've given both
men and women a way to there you go just
like that
anyways that happens it's the it's the
antagonistic reaction to being relaxed
so like you it requires relaxation you
are creating anxiety and stress so
interesting mnemonic very useful that is
point and shoot so parasympathetic
nervous system regulates eruption and
sympathetic nervous system which is the
Firefly regulates ejaculation and so P
point s shoot no yes yeah I think you
know deep breaths not breath yeah and
just concede the fact that like if you
if you put 10 pints and a bunch of shots
into yourself and you've been day
drinking on a bank holidays Sunday or
something mmm like there are men across
the world that this happens to yeah and
the problem that you have is that you
don't know that it's that comment yeah
especially when you're that age I think
and you're terrified of society so Mike
my experience happened like a few times
at uni and I remember thinking like oh I
got really hooked on no happens again
but it just takes a few conversations
and people as you get T 20s and
everyone's like you and I are actually
close to time this is really common yeah
but you know one when you're 18 19 nor
must be the first person to raise it
yeah guys I'm struggling to maintain my
virginity and during coitus so that good
tip in the condoms so I I saw a patient
who was statement they're not a state
Dukes people that was a joke do not stay
click on dogs
so a patient who freshers week was a
virgin had sex with one woman didn't use
a condom got a HIV but like yeah the
chance phase it is bro so you just you
don't know who using I think it was a
man yeah it takes a moment is like this
and the thing is the transmission rate
female to male or lower than male to
female this is
something else girls is like just
ultimate and lucky wait girls if you are
if you are listening your chance at
coolest michdan
your your chance of catching HIV at
catching HIV
catching an STI as a girl because of the
shape of your sexual organs
we just think what happens like you you
have a receptacle in your pelvis where
and people are shooting things into it
like possibly infected things that
segment back to your seller is gonna be
that that's gonna be the prima you have
a receptacle in [ __ ] hell
so yeah I think as much come and then
once you're in a relationship with
someone easiest way to do it if you want
to be hyper hyper safe both go get
checked because both of you should do in
any case together once you are go to
[ __ ] town yeah like mmm make sure
that she's on whatever form of birth
control that is appropriate for her I'm
glad you said that
what are supposed to just like start
making you baby whiskey are free just go
to town
don't get pregnant in the air oh yeah
so relationships relationships on that
one there what about what about making
friends and stuff like that so I've
suggested my my main one is joining
events company if you're if you like to
go out and you like to party and stuff
like that I think it's a fantastic way
sports teams
I'm sorry any tips on this I haven't got
any friends so I don't you've got a want
but we only friend by pay you to to it
was a donation that Johnny you did like
rowing and stuff right I did
interestingly so the there were two
types people that I encountered Ely
people who were obsessed about being on
like the rugby or the rowing socials and
all that sort of stuff and people who
very much just kind of like captain
solves themselves I was really good
friends with some of the people funnily
enough in my flat where I was like in
where I was a fresher and they were the
people who I ended up being really fun
really friendly with and I'm still in
touch with all now ten years later mmm
one of them has just another wedding
just got engaged asked me to be his best
man
really yeah so that's crazy so so so the
point where that is again like as I just
feel everything in my life like what
what are we trying to get out of this
like what's the what's the goal here
like being Batman do you want well yeah
I mean bingo don't completed it do you
want to leave uni with loads of like
low-level acquaintances that you know to
speak to after graduation or would it be
nice to have like a couple of friends
eve dect thrust of your life and so I
think there are a lot of people who paid
a lot of very diffuse attention to a
large group of people because they felt
like that gave them popularity in stated
that's a good point so I guess it
depends on the time line as well like me
it's like if you see your university
degree three years as a funnel you don't
have to narrow down in year one you can
spread your net wide feel out loads of
different types of people mm not
literally here oh yeah do not touch them
but just feel them all and then be like
actually this group who I thought I was
mates with it was just because of the
primacy effect young and then you want
to split that study its but yeah and you
know there's no problem with split
testing your social life because
ultimately it's it's a reciprocal
relationship as long as you understand
that it won't be true but touched yeah
it's labeled people it's all tribal
money like they're a fear I had was that
because of that because people are so
tribal I thought like are if I if I
don't like knuckle down are with that
group then I'm gonna lose them like a
finger I remember being at uni and some
of my friends been I also like who you
an out with tonight and they take a piss
are you going out with like the Pro Bowl
ads are you inside okay there we go
that's like that's the tribal nature and
the problem is if you are if you are in
a group of people who don't have a
sufficiently high level of emotional
intelligence to understand that this is
a good idea and that they should be
doing it to you become a victim of their
own insecurities yeah which is really
[ __ ] dangerous because if you
sequester to what they think you should
do you it's a very very [ __ ] slippery
slope it is projection isn't it a
project like this is what I think I
should be doing I think you should be
doing the same thing if you're not I'm
gonna criticize it's right Yaya I know
but a different group of people they see
you I wish I should I wish I was able to
go out with a different group of people
you're not going out with us therefore
you're out of our little social circles
yeah if that's the case then screw that
well just use it as a you can use it as
a big [ __ ] red flag about like this
present if ya know that as a tradition
stop loss stop loss you easily didn't
move there that into another and then or
Folio and I think another good point is
do not choose the flatmates you're going
to live with in second year or third
year in October and I see this happen
all the time like the number of people
and this is the second ear flat as
the rockiest doesn't it yeah it's yeah
you've just made the decision early on
and one of the problems is that because
good student accommodation good private
student accommodation is becoming more
and more competitive now that it's
common for a lot of the good flat well
priced flats to go by November December
time any like okay like there definitely
is a spectrum between wanting to go
early enough to still have a good choice
all houses but late enough to be able to
make a good choice of flatmates but I
can tell you a fine fact you would much
sooner live in a [ __ ] house with good
housemates than a good house with
[ __ ] yep so because I was attend
towards the latter like you don't need
to make the decision before Christmas
like if you have unless you absolutely
certain and you get on like a house on
fire with these people and you know all
of them another one as well
very few towns that finding a flat is so
competitively before what you'd be
surprised by Newcastle Newcastle is here
is one of those but for the really nice
wasn't many talking about you as well
I'd imagine like you're not you're not
totally like you will find somewhere to
live that is acceptable if you start
searching in March or whatever you know
it's not like you another thing to
consider I would refrain from living in
a house with any more than max five
people my daily floor okay because I was
in the seven unless second-year and we
chose it early on and if if we worked
out just about okay but okay I could see
it having gone very bad quite with you
split in third year into two yeah yeah
there was also a guy who we knew who did
a similar thing this group of people
like one of the guys on their corridor
they want to they like didn't want to
leave him are so they went they lived
with him and he ended up being a sex
offender
he ended up putting one of these like
fake USB sticks in the bathroom and
filming the girls showering and like was
saving the videos on his computer police
raided the house he threw his laptop in
like a bin on the street and ended up as
like so
so basically Jesus [ __ ] yeah
good story right there and I think is
well another another good point to
remember when you get into your second
and third year house is I would
genuinely genuinely advise at the
halfway point and then at the end point
just pay for a professional clean like I
didn't get series like that five person
house it's like three quid each or
something isn't it so so just to do it
do a halfway point so do it just after
Christmas before you come back to uni
pay for a professional clean on a 5min
house it'll be maybe 300 400 quid
absolute tops and that season
essentially like infested the place and
then do another one at the end because
it is not worth your time you do not
have the expertise the inclination the
time or the tools to be able to clean
your second year house to the standard
that it was when you move the only
deposit anyway yet so you may as well
there was a five five of us in a house
in judgment five hundred pounds each in
the DPS and we didn't get a single penny
every two and a half grand it cost to
get our house back to working order
there was well according to the agent
whereas met there was try honestly think
that New York were genuinely think we
got a deal
Wow like okay there was you got two and
a half grand of damage and you think it
was know how to read for the entire
kitchen because there were these maggots
that were powered by protein powder and
all of us a mixture of protein powder
and creatine so they're all grown to
humongous sizes yeah exactly
they were all in there benching pizza
crusts and that we have 210 bottles of
Tesco value vodka that were just like
strain ragweed spelled out remember when
you notice whistles oh yeah big thing no
so we had we spelled nuts out with the
bottles on a street with this over one
year one year and how many people in the
flat five so 200 divided by 542 so
that's one per week per person yeah this
is a very like consistent rate yeah well
they did they took the advice that we
gave of the son of your routine true ten
pancakes a day you just follow what was
what was what - don't miss a week it was
upon a time when Morrison's were doing
three liters of merinov vodka for 12
pounds this is before minimum unit
pricing carry on and I imagine you would
attract other thing you wouldn't have
just lived on vodka so that was majority
for me it was most calories it there was
a time as any calories there was a time
where we were so poor that all of us
were drinking water diluted juice like
dilute orange and vodka oh my god
together that's a cocktail because
that's three ingredients isn't this my
idea I won't wait what are you d choose
die linkages what we missed off your
list so I have a cleaning story okay
so I tried to clean my flat myself with
my one-year-old
oh no no so we looked at the price of a
cleaner like that we know thanks for
joining us witness went to like sorry
well higher like we'll just hire the
stuff we need and I can I just really
clearly remember the way this woman said
this so went into being cue went up to
the lady and being cue very little very
aggressive Scottish lady look to you so
if there's a group of people whoever she
was speaking to you she look straight in
the eye and we're going do you have any
cleaning equipment she's like no you
don't have any cleaning equipment she
said well we've got the rug doctor the
rug doctor doctor we'll take the rug
doctor which is this like yeah this is
it's a tower with the basically shoots
out water out the front of it runs some
brushes over it and then that's like a
dry brush at the back its shite
basically the doctor sort you know does
he have to see you for this like purple
stuff into this thing
push over the carpet did one road dyed
the carpet in one specific child just I
don't know why it's not the absolutism
us something to do with the carpet so
then had to do the whole house even this
color in the
you think and then they try to take the
deposit office because somebody left a
closed condom wrapper under the bed we
had used condoms under our bed when I
moved it didn't really air the agent
were just like well sorry mate and they
used condoms and loads of Maltesers on
the floor
well as what are the kids found here's
the ways here's a little hack for you
the way that as I'm slowly moving into
Landlord life and beginning to
understand this the way that the DPS the
deposit protection scheme works is to do
with the tenants returning the property
in the condition that it was moved into
it so what you actually really want is
for the condition of the property that
you move into to be as dirty as possible
while still acceptable hmm then complain
to the landlord of the wetting agent
they'll come round they'll clean it but
your inventory will be done at the
condition that it was when you moved in
so if you do move in take photos have a
little bit of a look if there's any
marks stuff like that just grab a couple
of snaps Evernote them nice and they
honorable and then in can set a date on
the Evernote to remind you them you know
here it is very unknown oh yeah there
you go
you basically you want it to be as low
as possible so that when you end up
moving out you're like well that's cool
no doctor only other thing on my social
list just visit your family occasionally
like don't just completely sack them off
but also I mean it's difficult giving
advice like this because some people are
proper home bodies and they'll they'll
go home every week and have their mum
come and do that laundry like which I've
seen so but as they like to come up to
like across the country to come and do
their laundry and then so that's it's
difficult but basically see your family
a cadence of once a month probably the
safe mmm but I think another thing to
consider as well which I never ever did
at uni was that you've left your mom and
dad and and family back home and the
dogs and stuff like that and although
you're having this fantastic time your
parents probably miss you life just went
on for them as
so they're now in the house and there's
no mom no more use of mess anymore
there's no more like him coming in from
college and talking to you about how his
days been like think about if you were
then like if you were a parent you'd
want to feel like you were a part of
your child's life as it moved away to
uni so invite them up let's show them
your University room like if you've got
a sports game that you're playing out or
if you're doing a play or if you've got
a presentation for uni or if you've got
whatever like invite them up to it
because that very good point they'll be
very meaningful experience for your
parents like there's so many
relationships mature relationships that
go to seed and people's parents split up
during the first couple of years of
university because the final thing which
bonded these two adults together was the
rearing of this child
and I'm not saying that you inviting
your parents of once every six weeks is
going to save their marriage but it's
definitely at least going to make them
feel a little bit better why I saw what
happen I saw someone witness the breakup
of the parents in by the first of the
vini grin it's mad man like yeah it's
like texting as well yeah it's like just
just like you should Kiki your spend if
you're spending eight hours a day on
your phone like you can afford and like
they have played a massive part in
getting you to that point because in
alien birds with condoms and like doing
all the fun stuff like it still doesn't
mean you can mmm make a time to tell any
parent just not wildly nailing a bird
with a condom mmm I just I can't um I
saw you oh man oh man you can nail or
tame it or yeah well I don't use other
people's olive oil as a Lube when you're
having an orgy especially when they've
just bought it for 3.75
[Laughter]
I woke up the next day where's Oliver Oh
suing me you had an orgy last night yeah
like what with olive oil yeah I mean why
you showed me photos as well I was like
guys like I'm just bought it wasn't even
open thing that clicked oh I mean I'd be
sad about the use of the olive oil but I
wouldn't feel disgusted because it would
be almost impossible to put it back in
that's true yeah it was one of those
like dispenser bottles as well so yeah
even then we're gonna do is scrape up
and down the skin you know what you
should do to protect yourself from that
one if there's like one Cal sprays yeah
not good no one's going to use in there
probably serve an orgy with it if you
put slow things down be significantly
yes this is only one calorie yeah it's
like a one zero spray isn't it it would
be like a pullout and it scores have to
keep there to pull out and they'd be
using keep reapplying yeah they'll be
using Gary's butter instead so the other
categories I've got so we've been
through academic we've been through
social and relationships and fatness
fatness yeah but less physical and
financial left
let's go financial at din okay so the
the point that Johnny made earlier which
is very very well purr of a degree is an
investment and so when people be like
when people are it like when people be
like setting up a business is a business
but this is too risky it's like you're
putting yourself in sixty grand of debt
to go and do something that is it's not
our university is that well for nine for
me 9 grand a year times six years plus
living costs so yeah pretty but
remembering that first but the tuition
fees for all of our first degree at nine
percent as well nine point one percent
is the new because it's six point one up
until twenty four thousand but anything
above that point like mortgage levels of
debt this year I think just suck coffee
student - pay minimum or goods of good
at Paraguay or Cayman Islands and just
anyway um so yeah it was somewhat it was
Nate Smith that said you are taking on
like a huge amount of debt to go and
work a job that guarantees like 30 grand
a year for life maybe with a slight
incremental
that's much more risky than starting a
business for example so do start a
business do like you know it doesn't
mean that's not mutually exclusive
because its finances outside of uni or
while you're out you both so remember
that like uni itself is a isn't
investment and so make sure you pass it
cuz otherwise you've got the worst of
both worlds you just committed to the
debt plus the yeah so that doesn't go
away just because you failed oh god yeah
exactly
um it's just Tim already granted you
never and above like what is it 15k I
just crease below the radar
well yeah who's the right now but the
point is you are there to maximize your
return on my investment so you've
already committed to the debt even if
you don't feel the the cost of that
because of student loans until later so
make the most of the opportunities that
you are there an academic hub where
there are people around you that are
complete sources of knowledge like you
professors the people around you the
libraries other people the course so
just soak it up how many student
discounts as well and just take as much
as you as much as you can that's
designed to feed you during that time I
would be interested to hear your
thoughts on whether or not you would
advise people to take a year in industry
or I think Johnny probably has weimar
right between second and third you know
why if you get paid and so again knowing
you to take you to visit so probably all
in industry all right now I didn't do it
hopped out over that exit sometimes
buzzes the mic is okay I think the year
industry what you're trying to get out
of that is do I want to go into that
line of work
and I think you can do that in a lot
less time than a year I got to say yes
if you get like a salary or prorated
salary I would I would only be talking
about if you got a like I think a
typical like internships maybe like 18
grand for the year I suppose that the
two benefits are it potentially gets you
a job in following assuming you like it
gives you the information they you the
like it or don't and it pays you but it
delays you as well so that so I did to
intern
summer that were of that format just
shorter I thought one was five weeks
when was first time I met you like she
yes I was doing one of them yeah and
then was eight weeks long I got offered
a job at the end of woman mercy still
paid see this I could get the job offer
yeah it's like a summer holiday
basically you get a flavor of but I
remember thinking I don't wanna do
either of these things but but I think
it's nice in the back yeah I think
that's definitely so my approach to how
I would plan my university years now if
it was me is I would do University yeah
study then I would do a summer abroad as
probably a party rep or something so
yeah because the intensity of experience
that you're going that you end up having
I did in between this is a terrible idea
in between my bachelor's and my masters
I did a left at masters again I did a
year in Ibiza now one of the problems of
doing a year and B through as I came
back and my mind was about 75% of the
speed before I'd gone out there so they
took a little bit time for me to get
back up to operate it that's not a year
in industry net or supposed no he's
likely it is my point my point is that
you get a you get to experience a lot of
partying over the summer I would also
advise a year in industry and my reason
for that is that by the time you're 21
and you finished if you've never spent
any consistent time working now with the
internship summer internship that kinda
gets around this what with my model of
going away and working abroad in
megalith or my major lab you can't do
that yep if you've never been in a 95
and felt what it feels like to sit in an
office all the time you are going to
tumble out so one of my flatmates JT
he'll be listening
he went did three years of Eunice's
before placement years were really a
thing year as an industry really thing
and he tumbled straight out of uni 21
years old into the LD graduate scheme
it's intense
60 Plus hours a week here working in
Middlesbrough living with us and he done
his six weeks of being a checkout person
and he was on for 40 grand like you're
20 years old on 40 grand a year
Oda for outside like forth and it sounds
fantastic but he'd never wanted to work
in retail he didn't want to do 60 hours
a week of work and this guy's now just
left a job at Bloomberg to go work at
Blackrock right anyway okay that's the
level that you're operating on and I
think that delaying the Delaine you're
entering into the working world first
off if you do your own industry yeah
it's a go of work but if you can get it
in the city where you're at uni you get
to spend it with your other University
flatmates that are still studying yeah
and you extend you essentially extend
your degree me whilst not having to pay
whilst earning some really really good
money you get to understand what the
working world feels like you have a bit
of liberation in a bit of a break yeah
you're gonna have to get back into
academia which is maybe not going to be
so easy because you've ungreased that
groove of learning a little bit but I
think it's a I think it's a really good
idea and I would from my side I mean me
and Darren went to college I went to
Rome Scotland carnage father and BBC
Radio Parliament featureless because
they didn't like us at all and we had to
essentially flee the country well but so
I found you that I found a couple of the
quotes that I was looking for from this
guy mate remit so he's a bit of a
outlier because he quit college so he
set up a drop shipping company was in
business school as soon as he made his
first thousand dollars drop shipping he
was like actually why am i in business
school now and just left so he says I
have a passionate hatred for modern
business school I paid thousands to
learn nothing nothing of value then I
spent my free learning free time
learning copywriting online for free and
started making more money than my
professors in less than a year
terrible ROI College the purpose it the
purpose isn't fun but it is a lot of fun
to be there at least
and where is it yeah a friend of mine
graduated with a business degree 50k in
student loans applied to 40 jobs
entry-level didn't get a single one
moved back home now taking real estate
classes dude can't even get a 40k per
year job with his degree but yeah
definitely go to college take out
thousands of student loans learn how to
follow rules don't lead get a job
building someone else's Empire mediocre
phaser breaks Yousef like don't let this
be you stop it you cast it gonna be
knocking down you dog
so I think yeah totally I do get that
we've got to see both perspective that
someone who is another like yeah but I
think what what you can definitely take
from that and what I think is a good
thing to take away is don't be scared of
changing a course like you've only
committed one year and yet it's one
video that you have to read this one
arcs I'm not allowed to know it's such a
good one
imagine a product that doesn't allow
refunds doesn't guarantee results has
dramatically increased in price has
dramatically decreased in value
encourages taking a massive debt if you
can afford it that is legally
inescapable this is called college wake
up if you're at university you do well
so why is this one hour and twenty
minutes into the podcast for all three
of us people started what the businesses
that we have at university talk about
I'm the fund like number one of saying
that University was for me a waste of
time
the difference is I don't think it was a
waste of money because it was three
thousand pounds a year
I see like it's a it's made you a
different person and I think like even
if it doesn't get you a job at Ernst &
Young like it's not about that
necessarily it's about who has grown you
into and I think there's nobody saying
that hedge
your income and developing multiple
sources of income is a bad thing
regardless of what you end up studying
or doing I think don't be don't be
scared of changing your course if you
get halfway through the year and you're
like right I can't switch anymore right
okay no you can't but you can
been that year you've got your friends
at uni switch to a course that you're
going to like like even abilities will
allow you to move internally without
having to reapply yeah Ryan you can i I
wish I still to this day wish that I'd
done philosophy or psychology in certain
I knew at the time that that's where my
passion lay but I was I was very
attached to the idea of a degree having
a linear trajectory towards a profession
and my terrifying fear was if I do
philosophy what job does that get me
into and whereas sure why I should have
actually thought he's what skills does
it give me and in terms of university
yet the four sites at 18 I was just like
nah me neither but to be a business man
I'm gonna do business that was no it was
like a business so what did you all want
to be when you started you [ __ ] knows
probably a business owner which is why I
actually ended up being but one of the
problems was I got to see very quickly
so did business management at undergrad
very quickly I got to experience what
running a real-world business is like
and doing Club promo for all that it
could promoters get accused of being
glorified party boys you get to see from
the ground floor you get a very very
good cross-section of everything from
finances logistics operations marketing
advertising HR you do everything any
like right okay so each of the modules
that I had at university I was going
into a lecture and learning something
then coming out looking at my phone and
experiencing the real world and I was
like what the [ __ ] am i doing learning
about Henry Henry Ford's scientific
model of management when everything that
I'm experiencing in the real business
world and I know it's the real business
world because we're making thousands of
pounds a year doing this business it's
showing me that it's useless but that
was exactly my experience at this
degree I did a module in
entrepreneurship because I was like you
know what the only thing so far has been
so dry in like operations research and
linear programming and stuff that didn't
have any high zen yeah it was like how
Welsh's grape juice run their algorithms
to allocate grapes from different
sources to make the flavor the certain
there's like this is completely
irrelevant so i was okay
module an entrepreneurship and it was it
turned out to be history of
entrepreneurship in the 1930s on and i
was like this is told us nothing about
so i think i think that anyone who's
doing a business degree should we really
be cautious about [ __ ] the popular
because you're not going to have
successful businessman teaching you
they're not gonna be lecturing you it'll
be academics that actually most likely
don't have an extensible business of
their own by definition because they're
not in the job that well after anton
yeah as antonio so these teachers are
just [ __ ] failures will link will link
the video maybe actually get rid of us
and Antoine will appear here like the
schoolteachers obviously the vast
majority work in the public sector but
even if you've been to a private school
it's very very unlikely that any of
these people have had a modicum of
success anywhere in the life so in terms
of financial education they can't teach
you anything
how about three years were sat in a room
and Anton came in eating scrambled egg
and toast I was a tree in a bowl ok but
actually that's really I thought we
wrapping up soon we'll get wraps
miss D physically of course I would I
wish so much and I don't feel like it
was available as much then maybe that's
just a didn't I didn't see any of it but
getting some kind of concurrent
alternative education while I was only
from podcasts books you should know I
mean now I thought people's capacity to
be able to learn stuff like do a couple
of like if you're doing 30 minutes of
work a day the minimum affected those
throughout he fractures he was thirty
minutes reading I did enroll in Mikey
to me course or like do not say that you
have no time because most people read
thousands of words a day but it's from
some newsfeed or like something
completely ass another anecdote Linda
trade live copywriting there was no
sales so I gotta believe you if you have
those they were far more valuable than
you'd agree and you're learning
something else do it in your spare time
if if I was if I was back at uni
actually the job that I would get if I
didn't want to be a promoter another job
that I would do would be get funding to
or use some of my student loan to get Pt
qualification because I think that
pretty much unqualified I am aware that
there is PT level three is a genuine
qualification and pts out there I
apologize but it's a [ __ ] couple of
weeks course yeah easily code agree that
it is a terrible my point is and anyone
who relies on their PT level three is
like the source of their but my point is
it from from starting point to qualified
the take off is rapid get yourself a job
at the gym group and you're owning
thirty five pounds an hour earlier and
you could be 19 or 20 flexible as well
so you could do thirty five pounder and
even though it blows my mind that
Petey's get paid that much it's
fantastic it's an unbelievable route to
get into and you go right okay I need to
do what that surly ten hours 20 hours a
week
ok that's between 350 and 700 pounds a
week which of you limit any part which
of Leoni much just do in your weekends
Benny weekends for most of the time your
uni work during the day is a good point
actually I couldn't like I think we
could have done that quite easily and
yeah you just said well I mean the gym
the pure gym know our stuff didn't exist
but yes yes we could I think I mean
that's what a fantastic option for ya
there's no speaking of gym
yes thinking about this and it's gym
coming I think he's he's on his way but
video Roger what do you guys do um so
physical yes I've covered academic
social relationships financial yep
physical you are between 18 and 25 there
is no excuse for you to not be in good
shape at that age you are a walking ball
of steroids so if you're if you're
listen skinny fat and untrained and you
have the full capacity to train in you
you aren't you're wasting a huge
dimension of your life and of your body
and it only gets harder from then on in
and if you if you miss that window and
you only start training when you're
thirty when you think you've got more
time or when you're 40 you've missed on
that window of potentially being able to
build the base of a physique that you
can carry for the rest of your life
that's a really good point what's
there's a it's a specific window I think
it's between the age of like 12 and 18
or is it 12 and 14 or something which is
when people make particular physical
adaptations then they're more pronounced
later in life I've got to presume that
there's a tail off that will occur 18 20
21 etc etc but you totally right like
the fact that the one of the only
reasons I think that any of us are in
good shape is the fact that we start
training when we were 18 years old like
I could never train again for the rest
of my life go back younger energy for us
yeah go back in the gym at 40 years old
45 years old spent six months in the gym
no back in good Nick value and even just
the time alone but also the the
endocrine profile the hormone profile
that you had at the time was so
conducive to muscle gain and so the
other mistake is like either not
training at all or training but
constantly cutting constantly trying to
be there shredded okay so give me a very
easy I'm at university I'm a girl or a
guy what's the split that I'm going to
do how am I going to Train
so first class goes for girls as well
don't think just in terms of muscle mass
and whatever it's like yeah so first off
I would say that a good opportunity to
get around this if you don't like the
idea of training if you're not into
maybe training on your own first off get
a training partner that may help
alternative would be start doing a sport
like if you're playing netball you'll
have netball training if you're doing
rowing you're gonna get absolutely be
caned with some good conditioning work
rugby's gonna have some good s and C
coaches in there you're gonna have a
community of other people around you but
if you're not doing a sport like that
remembering that every you knees got
books [ __ ] table tennis badminton
like
Ultimate Frisbee whatever is there's
something for you but if you don't want
to do that and you're going to go on to
a training split
what's the suggestion so get as lean as
is reasonably practicable so just like
below 12 percent body fat so like either
from body yeah so for a guy or a girl
abs almost showing is lean enough if you
leaner them great and then just spend as
much time as possible gaining muscle
don't go [ __ ] and fat bulking don't
give you membership at the KFC Club just
be a slicer plus see you gaining two to
three hundred grams of a month for the
whole of your degree and if you really
feel like you spilling over with body
fat spend two or three weeks cutting and
get back on the phone you see an abroad
um what were they doing in terms of
training three days a week
can I just add on to that an alternative
so if you do if you're someone who's
very visually focused who isn't that
bothered about cuz I ideally you're in a
calorie surplus or maintenance the whole
time if you are gonna cut I would cut in
third term I cut one exams Iran so don't
let it get in the way of the rest of
year so like that was something we both
did right I think yeah which was dieting
when exams okay makes more productive as
well you gonna be the library you
distracted anyway Tim wants him to so
like starting uni now just forget about
body fat well don't forget about it but
don't forget about cutting have to terms
like 20 weeks or longer of just built in
muscle and in the last term if you want
to die for some holiday do it then
that's the alternate but ideally you'll
see I just think it's hard as an
eighteen year old guy you're extremely
yeah visually favor I think I think that
a lot of guys are at least when I was at
uni a lot of guys were just concerned
about being massive right the biggest
guy was the best guy so I said I have
this race to hide the masculinity
because no one's no one is yet showing
any outright signs of super masculinity
because you're all just basically big
children this is the difficulty isn't
because we're trying to give advice for
the two sides but yeah for the people
because I know exactly the kind of
person you mean that
tries to get massive and a lot of the
time they they overshoot and they just
get far then there's nothing like the
girl the girl that founds to remain the
girl that wants to remand get to a size
four like some unbelievably tiny size so
they're just constantly on the stepping
machine yeah it's like I'm telling you
now that guys will find you more
attractive you will be more healthy and
you will enjoy the shape of your body
more and it will be more sustainable for
longer and your maintenance calories
will be higher if you've got a little
bit of muscle mass and loss and that
does not mean you actually look like you
have muscle it just means that you look
like you have some shape to your body
yeah my yeah again I'm gonna fly the
flag for it join a CrossFit box like I
don't think as someone at university
you're the gym where I go I think a
normal memberships 79 pounds a CrossFit
membership now is 49 pounds as a student
yes 49 pounds a month that is expensive
but you essentially have a PT for seven
days a week doing a class like if you're
someone who's really into their
athletics consider price to pay like I
think never shy away from investing with
yourself especially like a gym
memberships 49 around a month like you'd
spend that in vodka easily so yeah you
spend that two nights out both
alternately hire a coach hi Raj I've
just finished work with someone who's
just finished uni so he's been at uni
for four and a half years and I he's
just finished working he's off to work
somewhere exotic
but this before and after he is it took
the a different person really massively
different person and he's his
perspective on it is like it completely
reshaped mine because he we've all
experienced it you go from being like
not that big to being the person who is
very big person and that impacts how you
feel about yourself and when you're
going through that phase of your life
having that as a something to fall back
on like I got this right so yes great
something that I eat that I always used
to think while I was a uni was I would
never ever miss a training session and
the reason I wouldn't have a miss a
training session was because I knew that
if everything else in my life had gone
backwards that day because it's so
turbulent right now and we come back to
the fact that you don't have a
tremendously big sample of life to work
with almost every experience especially
when you've just moved away from home
everything's novel you've never dealt
with this before so you have no idea of
how to model what is going
like now for me it's very rare that I
have a new experience and I everything
is some version of something I've
already dealt with so I've got if they
think is why your life speeds up as you
get because guys are saying Gretchen
Rubin the Happiness Project you should
check out if you want to learn how more
about how to extend your remembered self
life through the use of novelty but yeah
I remember that I always used to drink
so I was like if I [ __ ] it today if
everything's gone wrong and I had now
you meet the girlfriend in tobacco and
add this there any other I know I've got
a good training session and my body's
progressed point not one of them son
which is a nice way to do so any parting
thoughts on how to survive University
final thing on physical is to get a slow
cooker or a rice or something
but yes it just requires minimum
competence at baking food you can just
put a bunch of frozen stuff in or
whatever and it makes something that is
possible as a meal and then you're not
relying on like plain pasta or dominoes
every day super cheap as well super
super cheap I actually got an email off
someone asking if I was going to make
that slow cooker Evernote to public and
I now have so if you want the slow
cooker recipes which are idiot proof is
in I can make them and they're
definitely uni student proof give me an
email email addresses in the show notes
and I will send you the servant my rice
go could just broke over eight years
instantly bought another one like didn't
make tin hau second thought and I've
tested the fuse first trying to perform
CPR on didn't work Borneo and parting
thoughts on life at University try to
not leave with a regret or try to
minimize regrets how do you know what
you're going to regret so I think
they're it's a tough one but I think
saying saying yes to as many things as
you can like if there's something that's
tempting and you find yourself saying no
to something because like you're worried
about are you to do this assignment or
I am worried about my calories or
whatever like things that went through
my head Rosie unis just have as many new
experiences as he can because it's like
a period of life where ultimately I
think probably all of us I feel like I
went in like 18 year old kid and came
out like I feel completely different now
so I think those experiences shape who
you become so breadth of experience is
important I think come stop clinging on
to what you think is safe or you will
all of those new experiences will
completely pass you by it is possible to
pass your degree and enjoy every new
experience that you want to you're fully
capable of doing that you're the one in
charge of your time and if you use the
tips we've discussed you'll be able to
do all of that and have a really full
day and I'm really rich life experience
in those three years I think we is I
think that's really good way to put it
the if I'd known attempted the stuff
that we've gone through today of how
organized my life or the fact that I
shouldn't double down on any one set of
experiences so I became like big dick
party boy like that was my thing and it
meant that I missed out on a lot of
experiences that would have occurred
during the day so I just thought oh well
I'm not gonna go to the trip to
Hadrian's Wall he's like Dutch rubbish
like no I'll go out and get lashed with
the lads all day drinking Osborne Road
from 11:00 a.m. when spy bar opens like
it's gonna be just the same as when you
day drank last week at 11 a.m. when
Spybot that's so insidious as well
because if that's what you spend your
week doing in the next week very soon as
the end of the year you've missed out on
that richness of life experience and you
have become a more boring more basic
person that is gonna carry you for the
rest of your life yeah and so to
slippery slope or to wear a condom well
you know that's it that's what this
happens you should be called wear a
condom or wear a condom oh yeah
right right
[Music]
you